significance with Abraham when he took
his son up as it you know the
sacrificial lamb but they saw a ram
instead of a lamb yeah have you heard my
session on this I've done many sessions
on this because in Genesis
22:78 Abraham tells the son when the son
says the fire is here the wood is here
where's the lamb Abraham says God will
provide a lamb for himself myself my son
then we go to Genesis 2213 and we see
that he found a ram which is not the
same as a lamb don't let anyone tell you
otherwise you know that means it has
horns caught in a Thicket Bush and the
ram was sacrificed in the place of Isaac
so the ram died to spare Isaac as a
picture of substitutionary atonement why
because the Lamb of God was still in the
future and we know this because if you
read Genesis
22:14 Abraham called the place Genesis
22:14 Abraham called the place Jehovah
Gyra yahovah
because on this Mount God will provide
God will provide on this Mount now that
was the mount in Moriah right because if
you go to Genesis 22 verses 1- two God
said go to Moriah and offer your son on
one of the mountains
right yes okay so it says on this Mount
God will provide meaning Abraham Knew
prophetically by the spirit that God's
provision is still future
right now is everyone else listening to
this are you guys following this he's
talking about Abraham telling his son
Isaac that God would provide the lamb
but instead of a lamb God gave a ram
instead that was caught in a Thicket in
a thorn bush and the ram was killed in
the place of Isaac to SP spare Isaac
then in Genesis 22:14 Abraham
prophetically by inspiration of Holy
Spirit called that mountain which is in
Moriah
Jehovah Jehovah Gyra that's where we get
the word Jehovah Gyra
yahovah because it means Jehovah
provides and Jehovah will Pro provide on
this Mount does anyone know why that's
significant if you're paying attention
does anyone know why that's significant
that Abraham called that mountain in
Moriah Moriah the region that specific
Mountain Jehovah Gyra saying because
it's on this mountain God will provide
does anyone
know no not because the Son of God died
there there are people who try to
connect it I haven't found conclusive
proof because Solomon's Temple was built
on that mountain the temple where burnt
offerings and other offerings would be
sacrificed to God 2 Chronicles 2
Chronicles chapter 3 verse one turn
there and read it for
me
okay uh give me a second give me a
second okay 2 Chronicles chapter 3 verse
one the Temple of Solomon was built on
that very Mountain where Abraham offered
Isaac it's 2 Chronicles
3:1 okay I got it then Solomon began to
build his house of the Lord at Jerusalem
on the mount on Mount Mariah on
what Mount Mariah so Solomon built the
temple as a house of God and a place of
sacrifice where burnt offerings would be
offered on the mountain of Moriah the
very Mountain Abraham offered Isaac
so the spirit revealed to Abraham this
is the site where in the future would be
the place that God would offer and those
Temple sacrifices become a picture of a
greater fulfillment John 1:29 where John
the Baptist says Behold the Lamb of God
who takes away the sin of the
world beautiful oh my gosh man you
always give me goosebumps dang it it's
not my good looks that's for sure
yeah that's for sure and then the ram
wasn't
the sacrifice that Abraham envisioned
it's Jesus Christ Our Lord which the
temple which was built on the very
mountain in Mariah where Abraham offered
Isaac was a picture of because Jesus's
physical body is the living temple of
God and he's the Lamb of God who takes
away the sin of the
world so that's the picture now again
the RAM does point to Jesus in one sense
notice the Ram was caught in a Thicket
thorn bush well what did they place on
Jesus's head a crown of
thorns is there a connection between God
ordering the sacrifice of Isaac and the
sacrifice of Jesus definitely now I
don't know how much time you want me to
take on this but I'm I'm I'm sure we'll
be because we we were focusing on the
deity of Christ but uh these are all
kind of kind of connected this one's
kind of loosely connected so if you want
to give a brief answer here um but I'm
sure be spending more time on uh on some
of these issues in future live live
streams I I think maybe in another
session we'll talk about where do we
find in the Hebrew scriptures the
prophecy of Messiah will be raised on
the third day and that will give us time
to then unpack Genesis
22 with greater depth because the Lord
does say in Luke
24:46 and Paul also agrees which he has
to because he's speaking by the spirit
of Christ in 1 Corinthians 15:4 that the
Hebrew Bible prophesied Messiah would be
raised on the third day and one of those
prophecies has to do with Abraham and
The Binding of Isaac so real quickly if
you read Genesis chapter 22 verse 1-2
I'm going to do it real quick guys I'm
speaking fast because we want to talk
about the Incarnation though this is
Loosely connected in Genesis 22: 1-2
note the point of similarity between
Isaac and Jesus Isaac said to be
Abraham's only begotten son in the
Hebrew it's y only son whom he loves New
Testament Jesus is God's one and only
son his only begotten son whom he loves
interestingly
the Greek word that John uses to denote
Jesus's unique relationship to the
father is monogan monogan only begotten
John 114 John 1118 write these down guys
I'm going fast John 114 John 1118 John
3:16 John 3:18 and 1 John 49 those
passages Jesus is called
monogan Isaac is called monogan in
Hebrews 11:17 Hebrews 11:17 so here's
that similarity Isaac Jesus their
father's only begotten beloved Son
another point of similarity Isaac
carried the
wood that would be used to pretty much
sacrifice him if you go to Genesis 22
and you read verse 6 it says Isaac
carried the wood John 19:1 17 jesus
carried the wood the instrument of his
crucifixion the cross that's another
similarity it says that Abraham arrived
at his destination which is one of the
mountains in Moriah on the third day
Genesis 22:4 on the third day and that
was the day that Abraham was going to
sacrifice Isaac and so in a sense and
this is how Hebrews 111 17-19 reasons
Abraham thought Isaac was as good as
dead but he trusted God to bring back
Isaac to him to keep his promise
concerning Isaac so he assumed that God
would raise him back to life and Hebrew
says he did receive him back from the
dead figuratively speaking but notice
what day he received them back from the
the Dead the third day what day did God
the Father receive his only begotten son
his beloved back from the dead the third
day